[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de TV
78 le SAMU lundi 27 décembre voici les
titres
alors que la fin de 2021 approche quel
est le bilan dressé par les
établissements d'hotellerie de
restauration l'année a été une nouvelle
fois particulière pour le secteur avec
le covid-19 dans le président général de
Luminy de France est notre invité
l'occasion d'évoquer avec lui également
les perspectives alors qu'un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire cette nuit
aujourd'hui et des QR code sur les
tombes vous pouvez les apercevoir sur
certaines sépulture du cimetière de
Jouars-Pontchartrain une fois fléchés il
permet de découvrir l'histoire d'un
défunt le dispositif est développé par
une entreprise et puis direction
Rambouillet pour visiter la meunerie
installé au sein de La Bergerie
Nationale sur place le blé cultivé
transformé en soirée quelles sont les
étapes de fabrication découverte dans
cette édition
alors que la 5e vague de covid-19
continue sa progression en France la
campagne de vaccination elle se poursuit
compris pendant les fêtes et dans les
Yvelines 11-17 centre de vaccination
reste ouvert et dans les 2 prochains
jours mardi et mercredi dans les
Yvelines c'est le cas vous le voyez à
Bonnières-sur-Seine
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine et Poissy au
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines installé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et à
Mantes-la-Jolie aimé aussi à
Saint-Cyr-l'École
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse Versailles et
également à Vélizy qui compte de 6 ans
la ville de Vélizy avec son centre au
centre Maurice Ravel justement et au
centre commercial Westfield Vélizy 2 L
la plupart de ces 6 seront également
accessible pour la journée de jeudi sauf
à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse et aux
Mesnuls qui resteront fermé vendredi
seuls les deux centres de
Vélizy-Villacoublay reste ouvert aucune
ouverture dans les Yvelines le 1er
janvier en fin à dimanche seul le centre
de Vélizy 2 sera ouvert pour les
injections dans département
voyons Omicron en cette période des
fêtes Emmanuel Macron a présidé un
nouveau conseil de défense sanitaire en
fin d'après-midi ce lundi suivi du
Conseil des ministres où doit être
adopté le projet de loi transformant le
Pass sanitaire en passe vaccinal de
nouvelles mesures pour être également
annoncée pour contrer les contaminations
Jean Castex le premier ministre elle
doit s'exprimer ce lundi soir à 19h avec
moi par visioconférence pour parler de
ses éventuelle nouvelle mesure rester
aussi le bilan de l'année gentil on est
avec moi Bonsoir
vous êtes le vice-président général de
lui il de France et l'Union des métiers
des industries de l'hôtellerie vous êtes
également le vice-président au niveau
national de limite pour la branche
restauration parmi les nouvelles mesures
évoquer une qui pourrait concernés
directement votre secteur c'est le
couvre-feu qui pourrait être mise en
place pour la nuit du Nouvel An même si
cela ne semble pas privilégier un
d'après les informations de plusieurs de
nos confrères vous attendez ces
nouvelles annonces du gouvernement je le
disais ce soir à 19h avec appréhension
oui c'est toujours la surprise c'est
vrai que la restauration depuis le début
des fermeture des confits demander
couvre-feu ça tu as été un peu précipité
toute façon malheureusement les Français
se sont déjà confiné pour les
restaurants puisque malheureusement les
réservations je suis profondément a plus
de 50 % donc depuis depuis bien avant
les annonces officielles donc les
tracteurs ça a commencé par les
tracteurs à faire voir la totalité et
puis ensuite les restaurateurs en suivi
puisque évidemment
depuis depuis des années pas de problème
sur la restauration qui pourtant met en
place
et pour cette baisse des réservations
c'est aussi le cas pour les dîners de
réveillon de la nuit de la
Saint-Sylvestre c'est également qu'un la
baisse des réservations
sans compter que il n'y a pas que les
restaurateurs chez qui ont contrôlé
passe à 10h alors je le disais et aussi
un conseil un conseil des ministres un
qui se tient ce lundi ou elle doit être
entériner en tout cas ce projet du
gouvernement suis transformé elle le
passe sanitaire en passe vaccinal
semblerait que les personnes entièrement
vacciner pour être plus forcément il
faudrait c'est seulement les personnes
vacciné pardon je m'embrouille dans mes
propos qui pourrait se rendre au
restaurant pardon et le test négatif ne
suffira plus l'objectif c'est une mise
en vigueur une mise en œuvre de cette
mesure des le 15 janvier est évoqué
également Jean terlon dans ce projet
dois la possibilité d'ajouter justement
au passe vaccinal l'obligation de
présenter à un test négatif pour accéder
à certains lieux pour les lieux
culturels ou pour les restaurants
notamment cela se fait déjà en Allemagne
ou en Autriche qu'elle regarde vous
portez sur ces éventuelle nouvelle
mesure quel impact elle pourrait avoir
justement sur sur le secteur de la
restauration
bien avant
l'arrivée des clients dans les
restaurants puis ça devient compliqué
c'est sûr que l'application du mystère
[Musique]
obligé de fermer et de pas pouvoir
travailler normalement sans les aides
c'est la problématique si on dresse le
bilan de l'année pour le secteur de
l'hôtellerie restauration une année
forcément particulière et une
réouverture en juin pour les restaurants
et c'est forcément on dit une année
parce que il y a quand même du positif à
en tirer où c'est difficile juste avant
de trouver du positif dans cette année
le confinement on crée un séisme dans la
profession qui était déjà là tant au
niveau du personnel beaucoup de gens
commencé depuis longtemps à avoir du mal
à trouver du personnel parce que on a
comme métier comme infirmier pompier
policier
[Musique]
pour travailler donc économiquement on a
un manque de personnel pour avoir des
services normaux
normalement aujourd'hui
le nombre de place et puis on a
été dans l'obligation de faire
dans la semaine
c'est une revendication de de lui c'est
de demander encore plus triste parce que
c'était pas prévu d'avoir un mois de
décembre aussi mauvais voir au mois de
novembre aussi avec cette montée en
puissance décontamination d'un nouveau
virus qui a coulé tout le temps au mois
de décembre novembre décembre comme la
nuit
on
[Musique]
arrive pas à rembourser
aujourd'hui donc ça va forcément on sait
pas quand ça va s'arrêter on sait pas
quand ça va redevenir à peu près normal
et puis elle restriction aujourd'hui
pour aller au restaurant puis il y a de
peur qui sont pas d'abord des peurs qui
sont pas justifiées
évidemment si vous avez pas de rentrée
d'argent vous allez beaucoup de mal
donc le ministre des Finances est très
très à l'écoute de nos propres problèmes
sur 10 ans le remboursement il propose
de continuer jusqu'au mois de juin
merci Jean-Talon d'avoir été avec nous
et je le rappelle vice-président général
de lumillule de France et vous êtes
également le vice-président au niveau
national pour lumi sur la branche
restauration
ce sont les premières sépulture
d'Île-de-France à bénéficier de ce
service au cimetière de
Jouars-Pontchartrain 4 tombe possède des
armes et des QR code en étant en flashé
à l'aide d'un téléphone il permet de
connaître l'histoire d'un défunt à
travers divers support les détails dans
ce sujet de Céline charles et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
dans le cimetière de
Jouars-Pontchartrain
pixelisé sur les tombes depuis le 12
décembre 4 pierres tombales du cimetière
sont ornées de QR code une fois flasher
avec un téléphone il rediriger vers une
interface ou la famille du défunt peut
stocker jusqu'à 2 gigaoctets de vidéo
image ou texte il suffit de flasher le
QR code et à partir de là vous arrivez
sur notre solution avec qui n'est pas
une application à télécharger mais un
site internet donc en fait ça fonctionne
sur tous les téléphones et donc le QR
code et donc je passe poser positionner
la sur le côté gauche je vais tout
simplement le scanner
où trouver des des photos des images
dans les premières images concerne les
œuvre d'art que l'on trouve dans la
chapelle de l'hôpital et là vous avez
accès à toutes les histoires les trois
siècles d'histoire de ses sœur au centre
hospitalier qu'est devenu le centre
hospitalier de la Mauldre l'objectif
raconter l'histoire du défunt on va
pouvoir rappeler la vois la personne
en images des anecdotes de sa vie sa vie
tout court feuilletée ensemble l'album
de famille sur toi et tes pensées pour
les familles ou pour l'histoire
vraie trace des personnes qui sont
enterrés à différents endroits le caveau
des sœur de la charité et la tombe de
Jean Stanislas barrier ancien maire de
la commune sont les premiers à
bénéficier de ce dispositif les QR codes
sont proposés par l'entreprise
yvelinoise de GSI en partenariat avec
l'association Jouars-Pontchartrain et
l'histoire ça peut s'adresser à un usage
intime celui de la famille ou des amis
et également ce qui est intéressé
l'association Jouars-Pontchartrain est
l'histoire c'est va raconter l'histoire
de la commune au travers des gens
illustrent des gens remarquables qui
sont dans ce cimetière pour les
historiens c'est extraordinaire tu en as
vraiment envie de raconter les histoires
et a moins de l'écrire dans un livre où
on fait toujours des coupures on fait
toujours à moi de se passe dans un
journal municipal ou autre on ne raconte
pas la vie des gens célèbres dans toute
cette mémoire enfui disparaît là on a
fait revivre de quoi dérouter
l'expression muet comme une tombe pour
la somme de 97 € vous pouvez vous aussi
faire vivre la mémoire d'un défunt en
contactant la société via le site Octus
vital
et puis découverte pour terminer ce
journal installé dans un ancien
poulailler du domaine de la bergerie
nationale Le Moulin de Rambouillet
transforme le blé cultivé sur place à
l'initiative de ce projet Magalie roseau
et Julie et xiberras qui s'occupe de
cette meunerie artisanale en préparant
des sachets de 1 à 5 kg et de farine à
nous font visiter cette activité avec
Nicolas d'entrée
[Musique]
je suis Magali Rose Hall à Jérôme des
moulins de Rambouillet nous sommes ici
sur le site de La Bergerie Nationale
implanté depuis maintenant 6 mois nous
sommes prestataire de service pour La
Bergerie Nationale ainsi que les
agriculteurs locaux qui souhaitent
transformée lors céréales sans farine
actuellement la farine de La Bergerie
Nationale qui est une farine de type
T110 ou T150 farine semi-complète ou
complète destiné aux particuliers ainsi
qu'au grossiste ou boulanger on vous
emmène découvrir aujourd'hui la mouture
de la farine de des céréales bio de la
bergerie
[Musique]
la première étape c'est le remplissage
des silos donc à la fin des moissons aux
alentours de la mi-août par La Bergerie
Nationale intérieur là nous avons du blé
qui est bio sont les culture biologique
de La Bergerie Nationale
de nettoyage du choisi de
faire cette cette étape elle n'est pas
obligatoire elle permet de retirer la
poussière et les petits les insectes qui
peuvent encore se trouver dans les
céréales
[Musique]
on se retrouve du coup après le brossage
donc on a une machine qui est ici et qui
nous permet de monter le grain jusque
dans le moulin c'est un moulin de
fabrication française il est monté sur
mail de Pierre c'est du granit et des
sur de melon en a une qui s'appelle la
meule dormante et on a juste une bulle
tournante en haut
de la Tréminou parce qu'une fois sous
les meubles pour ensuite suivre le
circuit je fais l'écartement des meules
s'ils ne sont pas serré ou écartés
correctement on va se retrouver avec du
trop de gras à la sortie alors que le
but c'est de récupérer toute la farine
et de n'avoir que du son à la sortie de
la Tamise aux
on peut
se retrouver avec la farine qu'on peut
appeler intégrale c'est-à-dire qu'à la
farine et également le son qu'il est pas
encore séparés
on a un cheminement et on arrive ensuite
dans la Tamise et
ça coule ici donc juste la farine
et on a le sang qui sort à la fin
la dernière séance à charge
faisant penser à acheter des sacs de 500
g jusqu'à environ 6 kg
et la toute dernière étape c'est la
couture
quels sont les étagères pour notre
producteur 1er donc La Bergerie
Nationale donc voilà on peut retrouver
une gamme de 1 kg de 5 kg
et ensuite 25 kg pour les boulangers on
produit pour la bergerie environ 45
entre 40 et 45 tonnes de farine par an
[Musique]
c'est la fin de journal merci de votre
fidélité rendez-vous demain mardi pour
une nouvelle édition belle soirée avec
TV 78
[Musique]